social
i'm told
congratulations daddy we are so proud of
you on your foot
awesome selection we love you
[Laughter]
there you go draymond how you like that
i love that and obviously they're
they're enjoying sunny beverly hills so
that's that's i hate it i would love
that too if i was you but they in front
of the gucci store and the louie store
and all that too
that's incredible i appreciate that
video
i love my girls my baby girl wasn't on
there but she's actually here with me so
it's great and then also little dj is
back here as well so i love them and i
thank you all for that video that is
incredible very good all right let's
move to the eastern conference give this
to chuckster
shuckster you get us started on the
eastern conference reserves
come on man start it out started out hot
ladies and gentlemen
the oscar goes to
from the miami heat jimmy butler
jimmy butler a six-time all-star in his
11th season now 22 points a game
six rebounds six assists the heat 32 and
20 have the second best record in the
east
seven games of at least 30's had four
triple doubles
[Applause]
missed some time earlier this season but
has come back
with some fire for the 32 and 20 heat so
jimmy butler the first of the eastern
conference
reserves chet oh it's back on me
ladies and gentlemen
our second reserve for the eastern
conference
from the cleveland cavaliers nice
darius garland very nice
nice winston your son made it
third season third season in the league
for darius garland in his first
all-star
selection he's given the cavs 20 points
a game
three rebounds eight assists he's number
seven in the league in that department
shooting 47
36 from deep
had three games of at least 30 and he's
had a triple double and darius garland
for the 31 and 20 cleveland cavaliers a
first time that's awesome man yeah
earn it and they don't just get the fan
vote and like a lifetime achievement
award this kid deserves to be an
all-star game first cavalier since
lebron left
to be an all-star wow and
now the third
reserve from the east
james harden
of the brooklyn nets
james harden in his 10th
straight
all-star game
22 points a night eight rebounds 10
assists he's number two in the league
there
he has had trouble shooting the ball i
mean this is his his low field goal
percentage since his rookie season and
his career low
from three
he's had nine games at 30 plus he's had
nine triple doubles
the 29 and 22 brooklyn nets represented
by james harden who already have uh
kevin durant as an all-star starter
all right shaq
sound it out big fella
[Laughter]
chuck i'm gonna whoop your ass that
sounded good enough
and the hip-hop social work goes to zach
levine chicago yeah sir yes sir well
deserved
absolutely i was second second
election yeah again
definitely should have been a starter
thank you that's his size i got caught
last week in his eighth season 25 points
a night for the bulls that's number 14.
five rebounds four assists shooting 48
12 games of at least 30. the bulls at 32
and 18 have the best record in the
eastern coast which is amazing with all
the injuries they've had okay yeah let's
move this one down to the chuckster
again
little something going on between them
all right they ain't gonna find his body
yeah
i'm like what happened to kenny no chuck
was on tv he's gone
from the milwaukee bucks
chris middleton christmas middleton yes
sir champ
this is his third all-star game in his
uh 10th season
he's given the bucks 20 a night six
rebounds five assists 44
shooting 38 from deep the bucks at 32
and 21 the reigning champions are number
four
in the eastern conference so chris
middleton joining zach levine james
harden darius garland and
jimmy butler we have two envelopes left
i sure you don't want one
yeah i'm going to take the last one okay
oh
and now
from the boston celtics jason tatum yes
sir for jason tatum his third all-star
selection his third straight in his
fifth season
26 points a night is number 11 in the
league also eight rebounds and four
assists
16 games of at least 30 points the
celtics
playing better lately they're up to 28
and 25
which is number nine in the easter this
is going to be
what do you think chuck there are a lot
of guys interesting what's one left one
left
um i'm gonna go
why don't we just announce it no yeah
yeah let him let him on now let's just
announce go ahead brother announcement
all right your last three months
from the eastern conference
from the toronto raptors fred and
vladimir oh congratulations well
deserved well
yes sir
and that's his first all-star game in
his sixth season
points a night five rebounds seven
assists wow that's some big numbers he's
12th in assists he's 22nd in scoring
eight games of at least 30 plus he's had
a triple double the raptors are 26
and 23 and so there
are your reserves in the eastern
conference
butler garland hardin levine middleton
tatum
and fred van vliet and a small
there were